au bleu du ciel ils ajoutent des touches
de couleur qui ravivent leur îlot
d'habitation
ici dans le quartier Fayard à
Saint-André des enfants des immeubles de
la SHLMR assistent deux artistes
c'est jamais facile mais c'est très
agréable parce qu'il nous donne envie
son plein d'entrain et puis bon bah
après on essaie d'être un peu
discipliné aussi on essaye de leur
montrer les bons gestes après ça dépasse
un petit peu mais c'est un peu ça la
peinture
les oiseaux de cette fraise prennent peu
à peu des couleurs
[Musique]
plus loin dans un autre groupe
d'habitation les fleurs ont fini de
s'épanouir rivalisant avec les habits du
vendredi de cette locataire
par la magie de quelques dessins
ils habitent le béton pour transformer
le regard et les habitudes
[Musique]
et on s'assitte
et comme là on a fait les peintures mais
on peut s'asseoir on peut jouer
dans ce quartier réputé chaud les coups
ces derniers jours
étaient uniquement de pinceaux
[Rires]
et tout le monde était ensemble
tranquille sans dispute sans rien sans
rivalité tout le monde vient dans
l'entente cet espace était vraiment
dégradé en fait par les enfants
l'objectif c'était de faire un travail
avec eux et sensibiliser ces mêmes
enfants notamment au tri sélectif après
on va mettre un petit message en
français en créole et en Mahoré en
disant en gros respectez notre quartier
Fayard un quartier qui se transforme par
petites touches